[Rires]
[Musique]
Comment avez-vous rencontré Kamela Harris en
entrant dans une autre école, nous étions
tous les deux nerveux et vous savez comment
allions-nous nous intégrer et comprendre que nous
allons le faire ensemble
ouais d'accord et que ce genre de
nous a amenés  plus près l'un de l'autre,
il venait d'une famille biraciale et
moi aussi et nous avions donc ce terrain d'entente aussi vous savez que
c'est comme si vous essayiez de vous intégrer,
vous savez êtes-vous aussi trop trop clair
pour le
trop clair pour les noirs et trop sombre
pour les blancs donc tu dois trouver ton
chemin
je ne savais même pas que camelot était si
riche
c'est à quel point ils étaient terre à terre que
je n'avais aucune idée
qu'ils vivaient en fait dans la colline à l'ouest du
mont kamala partages
elle aimait danser nous aimons danser alors
quand vous la voyez sortir sur scène
comme
danser sur la musique c'est toujours
comme ça qu'elle était vous pouvez devenir
vous pouvez regarder dans ma paume et voir la
tempête venir la
musique a toujours été une grande partie de sa vie
même à l'époque
alors
quand  j'étais au lycée  l j'avais
une meilleure amie kamela harris a publié une
vidéo en septembre je me souviens lui avoir demandé si
tout allait bien je l'ai juste senti
et elle m'a dit que son père l'
agressait c'était très c'était très touchant parce
qu'il y avait plusieurs fois je suis venu à l'école
avec
physique euh marques physiques de violence physique
et personne ne m'a jamais demandé j'étais tellement soulagée
que je me souviens juste d'avoir été très
soulagée que j'ai finalement dit à quelqu'un
et donc je lui ai dit dès qu'elle m'a dit
bien tu dois venir rester avec nous
harris partage
et je ne me sentais même pas comme un invité je
me souviens me sentir comme une
famille comme s'asseoir à la
table du dîner
j'étais fasciné par le fait qu'ils étaient tous assis à
la table du dîner pour dîner ensemble
je suis fier de créer
elle m'a dit je  est allé se battre pour les
femmes
et les enfants d'agression sexuelle après
avoir traversé ce que j'ai vécu
avec vous
et j'étais comme wow vraiment et alors elle
dit oui ça m'a vraiment affecté
je kamala davey harrison nous lui
jurons vi  Ctory signifie simplement que cela signifie plus que
juste comme quelqu'un qui gagne le poste de vice-président,
vous savez
comme si elle était la première asiatique afro-américaine,
elle est la première femme,
cela envoie ce message qui voit que
tout est possible, tout ce que vous décidez
de faire, vous pouvez le faire,
ce sont les mots de la mère de Kamil